MARKUS KLUTE: Welcome back
to 8.20, special relativity.
In this section, we want
to talk and investigate
a bit more length contraction.
We have seen length
contraction a few times
already in this class.
We have derived it.
We have seen it in application.
But we want to get
some sort of feeling to
how can we actually
understand what's
happening to the objects.
Later in this section,
in this video,
we'll talk about another
paradox, spacecraft on a rope.
So let's get to it.
So the situation here is as we
have seen a few times already.
We have Alice being
at rest, and Bob
is moving with a velocity v.
And what we are interested in
is this object here, which
might be a rod of some sort.
You can think about a
spacecraft if you want,
but a specific object, which,
at rest, has a length LB.
For Alice, this object
is Lorentz contracted,
and it appears shorter.
So now what happens now if Bob
accelerates from his velocity v
to a velocity v plus delta
v with respect to Alice?
How does the acceleration occur?
And how can we understand
then the further shrinking
of the spacecraft?
Bob tries really, really
hard to accelerate such
that all elements of
this rod or spacecraft
are being accelerated
simultaneously
in his framework.
You can think about
splitting up the spacecraft
into small elements.
They're all getting a
little bit of a kick,
a little bit of an extra
momentum at the very same time.
So, if now Alice observes
the same situation,
we find that she looks
at the spacecraft.
And, because the leading
clock in the spacecraft,
in Bob's spacecraft,
lags, she observes
that the spacecraft's back
is being accelerated first.
And, because it's
accelerated first,
she observes that the
spacecraft shrinks
just a little bit because
of the additional velocity.
Well, that's kind of
an interesting picture
to think about how we can
understand length contraction
and how we can understand
length contraction
once there's
acceleration involved.
OK, so the next question
now or the next topic
here in this video is the
spacecraft on a rope paradox.
This was phrased by Bell
in the 1950s and '60s.
He was working at CERN at the
time and roaming the corridors,
discussing with his colleagues.
The situation here is related
to the one we just discussed,
but slightly different.
So let me explain.
So again we have Alice
as an observer, observer
in a reference frame A,
observing two spacecrafts.
They are identical spacecrafts.
They have the same engines.
And they are separated
by distance D.
So now Alice gives a
signal to both spacecrafts
simultaneously in
her reference frame
to accelerate at
the same time such
that the distance between
B and C remains constant.
So they're asked to accelerate
such that the distance remains
constant.
Well, the question now is,
when those two spacecrafts
are connected with a rope,
will this rope break?
So I'll let you think
about this a bit
and come up with
your own answer.
In the meantime, this is not
such a hard problem actually.
In order to keep the
distance constant for A,
the distance in the
BC reference frame,
in the reference frame
of the two spacecrafts,
needs to expand.
So LA, so the distance as
observed by Alice or reference
frame A, is equal
to 1 over gamma,
the distance between
the two [? planes. ?]
And for this to stay--
for LA to stay constant
while there's acceleration
going on, LBC needs to increase.
That's why the rope will break.